all right let's go back to the phones at
6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 we will go first to our caller from
the 267 area code who's calling today
from 267 hello yeah that's you oh hey
David
my name is Devon from Philadelphia
hey house I just wanted and sup yeah I
just wanted to tell you like I really
appreciate what you doing man thank you
like home to just be honest with you
like you know one of those videos of
like people saying like oh they were
brainwashed into thinking like the
alright is like the truth the real truth
and the left is backs etc yeah I was one
of those people to the house a few like
this happened like I guess like a year
or two ago because I was originally
left-wing but um it's like rather Tron
guy elected I started watching like all
these videos of like I don't know just
like people did like the being left-wing
people and they're like they just get
mad so like that
hold on who were you watching who were
you watching on the right that appealed
to you and fours okay this is one yes
yeah there was debate people and like me
and then like they would make them seem
like super emotional like crybabies yep
you know and that and that appealed to
you on a like an emotional level yeah
kind of I just didn't want to associate
myself with those kind of people you
know because I wanted to I thought like
I wanted to be more mature so I thought
the right was way more mature you know
right so he I guess that that's very
interesting because it shows us the
importance of not only making the right
arguments but making them in the right
way but so like you're saying you were
left-wing on policy like you were mean
like so where were some of the things
you believed before you were sucked in
by it by Alex Jones
um well I kind of I kind of believed
like like I was you support like
immigration you know okay I like like I
didn't really like believe and all the
right-wing policies like immigration
majority like Leslie I was in support of
like immigration and all that so
basically because basically that because
I didn't really know that much about
like politics and policies and all that
it doesn't correct me if I'm wrong but
it doesn't sound like you were so much
left-wing as you were sort of just not
that involved in politics is that fair
to say
yeah yes yeah yeah that's fair yeah
that's fair because before I would I
didn't really know them what about
policies in politics or whatever yeah
you know but I was but I was like for
less lean presidents like Barack Obama
stuff like that I was in my house for
like the Democrats because like my
family's my family as majority uh Leslie
exciting I would just like go with them
but then like I would be like I would
think like the media makes Trump like
out to be like a bad person when he's
when he's not really then what's for bad
first that's why I was thinking before I
said me it was why stuff about him but
like that's what they maybe want to
believe because I'm looking people like
mark dice and like I felt and you know I
just thought like the dude was like like
he was speaking the truth and all that
like that but like I I was like such a
piece of [ __ ] back then I'm not gonna
lie I feel like such a pieces because I
guess so every every time you scared
just so you know we've got to bleep you
because of the broadcast but so you felt
you felt like a bad person I gotcha so
you were watching Infowars and you were
watching mark dice and anything else you
were watching in particular um no not
really not really not that I can think
of but those were like the main ones and
like I just felt like I just felt like I
had a lack of empathy for most people
like I remember back when I hurt like
that hurricane hit poor Rico yeah I was
watching uh it was like an interview
like this woman like reading for her
like loss of her housing and stuff like
that and I sure can
I've laughed I laughed at it and that's
you know looking back and now I felt
like you know I'm terrible person now
we're guys in love I don't know that it
does Alex Jones make you not care about
a hurricane victim that quite frankly
seems like it's related to other things
going on in one's life don't you think
yeah I mean I was just saying I
understand like I really I really hated
myself back then all right
like like people like you and Calculon
see like y'all walking back to like you
know having that high like you know
those good morals and stuff like that
because like I even I even told my I
can't try to tell my dad about it my dad
told me he died that he said like I
don't even know what I'm talking about
you know and looking back on it now he
was right mm yeah I'm understanding I
think the the circumstances well listen
I'm glad that it sounds like you're
doing better now and it sounds like get
a lot going on at the time I'm glad
you're not you know subscribing to
Infowars conspiracies anymore and yeah
yes luck alright my friend thank you
David
appreciate your phone call thank you